nevada state bake is donating the next
segment to las vegas rescue mission so i
spoke with them
with the mission themselves about their
annual toy giveaway and how the
community can help
check it out hey valerie welcome to the
show
hi thanks for having me absolutely i'm
excited to talk to you about las vegas
rescue mission and what you guys are
doing for the holidays
yeah we are having our annual toy
giveaway for
families in need this year and basically
it's going to be held on december 19th
it's a saturday from 10 a.m to 12 p.m
and it's really to give back to families
struggling this year
uh with the pandemic a lot of families
have fell on hard times
more often than they usually would um
you know it's affected so many and so
we're
really here the las vegas rescue mission
is here to help as many families as
possible this year
well thank you so much that is so so
important especially this year
um what kind of toys can people give
what are you looking for
we really want the community to get
involved and give back by donating toys
and they can do so by stopping off at
the las vegas rescue mission we're
located at 480 west bonanza road
and we're looking for all kinds of toys
you know these are
all sorts of families coming from all
over that are in need of help
so all genders all ages really just
anything the community can give would be
incredible for us beautiful and how can
the community help how can we get
involved
should we go to your website too to
donate
yeah there's multiple options so of
course like mentioned anyone can decide
to pick up a few toys while they're out
shopping for the holidays i know there's
a lot of great deals out right now
even though black friday and cyber
monday are over there's tons of deals
still going on and
generally we encourage those toys to be
valued under 25
so we're not asking for the big
expensive toys just a few things you can
grab while you're out
people can also make a donation online
monetary donation at vegasrescue.org and
that's also where they can find all the
information about the event
perfect well thank you so much valerie
for your service for the las vegas
rescue mission service and happy
holidays
thanks you too we want to thank nevada
state bank for sponsoring this segment
and being one of our community pride
partners